We've been doing a lot of stories lately on the radio show about police. And they've been pretty heavy, we know. This is not a story like that. In fact, kind of the opposite.
最近我们在广播节目中做了很多关于警察的报道，我们知道这些故事都很沉重。但今天这个故事不一样，事实上，甚至可以说是恰恰相反。
When Miles and Katie's apartment was robbed, they knew this was not going to be a big case. And if you got right down to it, they did not have a problem with that. New York City cops arrived after the burglary.
当迈尔斯和凯蒂的公寓被盗时，他们知道这不会是什么大案子，说到底，他们对此也并不介意。案发后，纽约市警察赶到了现场。
They had probably just come from some sort of situation where someone had gotten stabbed in the neck. And now they're in these kind of yuppies' apartment, and we're running down this laundry list of things that had been stolen.
他们可能刚处理完某个人脖子被捅伤的现场，现在却来到了这些雅痞的公寓里，听我们像念清单一样列举被偷的东西。
And the list is like--
那清单简直是——
Oh, it's so embarrassing. It's like, an iPad, an iPod, an Xbox.
哦，太尴尬了。就是iPad、iPod、Xbox这些东西。
They've got bigger problems.
他们有更重要的问题要处理。
Yeah, they got bigger fish to fry.
没错，他们有更棘手的事情要做。
Surveillance video from the building showed that the culprits were three teenagers who took the elevator to the top floor, probably jumped down onto a balcony, and then walked into Katie's and Miles' apartment through a sliding glass door. Then there's video of them leaving the building.
楼里的监控录像显示，作案的是三个十几岁的少年，他们乘电梯到了顶层，可能跳到了阳台上，然后通过滑动玻璃门走进了凯蒂和迈尔斯的公寓。之后还有他们离开大楼的录像。
Three teenage guys with three of our backpacks, stuffed full.
三个十几岁的男孩，背着我们三个装得满满的背包。
Wow, so they're using your backpacks?
哇，所以他们是用你们的背包搬东西的？
Our own backpacks.
用我们自己的背包。
So they didn't even have any plans on how they're going to carry this out?
所以他们连怎么搬走这些东西的计划都没有吗？
I guess not.
我猜没有。
It didn't seem like a very well-thought-out caper. This was more of a-- let's break into this building and see if someone's dumb enough to leave their sliding glass door open.
这看起来不像是个精心策划的作案。这更像是——让我们潜入这栋大楼，看看有没有人笨到把滑动玻璃门留着没锁。
Of all the things they lost, the only thing that they actually cared about was their video camera. And they only cared about that because it had their wedding video on it-- the only copy. Katie filmed the wedding to show her brother but hadn't yet.
在所有丢失的东西中，他们唯一在意的就是摄像机。而在意的唯一原因就是里面存着他们婚礼的视频——那是唯一的拷贝。凯蒂拍下婚礼是为了给弟弟看，但还没来得及。
My brother, who I'm really close to, couldn't come to the wedding. And so it was really sentimental, and I really wanted it back. And I was really upset. I was really, really sad about it.
我弟弟没能参加婚礼，我和他感情非常好。所以那段视频对我很有纪念意义，我真的很想找回来。我当时真的非常、非常难过。
So the morning after the burglary, knowing the police were not going to be much help on this one, Katie decides to jump into action herself. She goes onto Craigslist to see if the thieves have put her camera up for sale there.
盗窃案发生的第二天早上，凯蒂知道警察在这件事上帮不上什么忙，于是决定自己行动。她上了分类信息网站Craigslist，看看小偷有没有把她的摄像机放在上面卖。
And boom, she finds it immediately. Same camera in the same bag, with all the accessories that she had specially bought for the camera. It had to be hers. And she calls the detectives on the case, tells them the good news.
砰，她立刻就找到了。同样的摄像机，在同样的包里，还有她专门为摄像机买的所有配件。那一定是她的。她打电话给负责案子的侦探，告诉他们这个好消息。
Like, I can get my camera, and I can probably put these guys in jail. And he just immediately shoots me down and says, you know, "there's no way of really knowing if that's your camera. We can't help you with anything. The only way we'd be able to help you is if you got the guy to give you a serial number off the camera and if you happen to still have the serial number from the camera, and they match." And I think he was just thinking, like, that'll never happen.
我想，我可以找回我的摄像机，甚至可能把这些人送进监狱。但他立刻泼了我冷水，说：“你没法确定那是不是你的摄像机。我们帮不了你。除非你能让那个人告诉你摄像机的序列号，而且你刚好还留着摄像机的序列号，并且它们匹配。”我想他当时心里肯定在想，那种事永远不会发生。
Katie, however, saves all her warranties in a special folder. She does have the serial number. And to confirm that it's the same as the advertised camera, she calls the guy on Craigslist and she concocts this story that she is a girl who needs to buy the camera for a school project.
然而，凯蒂把所有的保修卡都存在一个专门的文件夹里。她确实有序列号。为了确认广告上的摄像机就是那个，她打电话给Craigslist上那个人，编了一个故事，说自己是个需要买摄像机做学校项目的女生。
She puts on this supposedly tough-sounding Brooklyn accent that I would describe as kind of the Brooklyn accent you would hear performed by a kid actor on the Disney Channel. I made her do this for me. You do not want to hear it.
她装出一种她自认为很厉害的布鲁克林口音，我形容那种口音就像是迪斯尼频道里的儿童演员表演的那种布鲁克林腔。我让她演示给我听过，你绝对不会想听到的。
And I told him that my boyfriend was going to kick my ass if I spent our last $300 buying a camera that broke the next day. And so, "Do you have the warranty for the camera?" And he said, "No." He was like, "Uh, I got this camera from my friend, so there was no warranty with it."
我告诉他，如果我把我们剩下的300美元拿去买了一台第二天就坏掉的摄像机，我男朋友会揍死我的。所以我问：“你有这台摄像机的保修单吗？”他说：“没有。”他说：“呃，这台摄像机是我朋友给我的，所以没有保修单。”
I was like, "OK, well, do you know, like, is there a way to find out if it's still under warranty?" And he said, "Well, I think you can find out if the camera's under warranty if you go online." And I was like, "OK, well, what do I need to do?" And he was like, "Well, I think you need to have the serial number."
我说：“哦，好吧，你知道吗，有没有办法查出它是否还在保修期内？”他说：“嗯，我想如果你上网查的话，应该能查到摄像机是否在保修期内。”我说：“好吧，我需要做什么呢？”他说：“嗯，我想你需要有序列号。”
So you didn't actually just ask him for the serial number. You wanted him to suggest the serial number?
所以你并没有直接向他要序列号，你是想让他主动提出来？
Yeah. Yeah.  Because I thought if I asked him for the serial number, then he would know right away what I was trying to do.
是的，是的。因为我想如果我直接要序列号，他马上就会知道我想干什么。
Wow.
哇。
So I was trying to get him to say it.
所以我当时就是想诱导他说出来。
She asked him, "Can you read me the serial number?" And he says he doesn't have the camera with them. He'll have to call her back. And she figures, oh, that's it. The jig is up. He knows she's lying. He will never call back.
她问他：“你能给我读一下序列号吗？”他说摄像机没在身边，他得回头再给她打过来。她心想，完了，被识破了。他知道她在撒谎，他再也不会打过来了。
As Miles points out, this story that she has made up, it really makes no sense at all. Like, OK, she's got a sociopath boyfriend.
正如迈尔斯所指出的，她编的这个故事根本说不通。好吧，她有一个反社会人格的男朋友。
Who would beat up his girlfriend over the very nerdy error of buying a video camera that wasn't under warranty.
谁会因为买了一台没在保修期内的摄像机这种书呆子才会犯的小错而去打女朋友呢。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
[LAUGHS] It wasn't like he was drunk and he found her cheating on him or anything. He was like, he's violent enough to beat somebody up, but only if they buy a video camera that we don't have a warranty for.
[笑] 这又不是他喝醉了发现她在出轨。他好像是那种暴力到会揍人，但前提仅仅是对方买了台没有保修的摄像机。
(IN HOLLYWOOD BROOKLYN ACCENT)  Because God forbid something should happen, you know, and this camera breaks down. "We can't get our money back! We can't get it repaired! You know what's gonna happen." It's like, what?
(用好莱坞电影里的布鲁克林口音) 因为上帝保佑，千万别出什么事，万一这摄像机坏了怎么办。“我们拿不回钱了！修不好了！你知道会发生什么。”这简直是，什么鬼？
And then the guy calls back. Gives her the serial number. Of course it matches. Katie calls the detective to let him know.
然后那个人回电了，给了她序列号。当然，完全对上了。凯蒂给侦探打了电话通知他。
He says, "Oh, really? Well, what should we do?" [LAUGHS] And I was like, "You tell me what we should do. You're the detective."
他说：“哦，真的吗？好吧，我们该怎么办？” [笑] 我说：“你告诉我该怎么办，你是侦探。”
And he says, "Of course, we'll do a sting. Call the guy and arrange to buy the camera from him. Set a location. We'll be there, too. We'll swoop in. We'll nab him."
他说：“当然，我们要设个局。打电话给那个人，安排买下摄像机，定个地点。我们也会在那儿，我们会冲进去逮捕他。”
15 minutes later, the police arrive to take Katie and Miles to the sting. Katie runs downstairs to meet the detective on the street.
15分钟后，警察赶到接凯蒂和迈尔斯去执行任务。凯蒂跑下楼在街上见到了侦探。
He tells me that there's been a change of plans. He doesn't need my husband to come anymore. He only needs me. I'm not going to meet the burglar face-to-face anymore, because it's not safe. And so he's got a different plan of how we're going to do this.
他告诉我计划有变。他不再需要我丈夫去了，只需要我。我不会再和窃贼面对面了，因为那不安全。所以他有一个关于如何实施这次抓捕的新计划。
At that point, Miles arrives downstairs.
就在那时，迈尔斯走下了楼。
I turn around to him and I just say, "Change of plans. They don't need us both anymore. They just need me. It's not safe for you to go. I'll call you when it's over."
我转向他说：“计划有变。他们不需要我们两个了，只需要我。你去不安全，等结束了我给你打电话。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER] And he's, like, stunned.
[笑声] 他当时简直惊呆了。
(LAUGHING)  'Cause that's not alarming at all.
(笑着) 因为这听起来一点儿也不让人担心。
(LAUGHING)  Yeah.
(笑着) 是啊。
Miles watches her get into the car and drive off. Inside the car, Katie says, the detectives tell her the new plan. She's going to stay in the car and talk to the guy on the cellphone, keep him talking as the cops go and grab them-- though they are very skeptical.
迈尔斯看着她上了车开车离开。在车里，凯蒂说侦探告诉了她新计划。她要留在车里，在手机上和那个人通话，在他和警察靠近抓捕他们时一直跟他聊天——尽管他们对凯蒂非常怀疑。
Basically saying, like, "The chance of this working out is so small." Like, "This is never going to happen. Don't get your panties in a bunch."
基本上就是说：“这事儿成功的概率太小了。这种事儿根本不可能发生。别太紧张了。”
She and the  Craigslist guy agree to meet at a CVS drugstore. Cops go inside. Then on the cellphone, Katie asks him, OK, "What are you wearing?" so she can recognize him. She tells him, "OK, I'm in the make-up aisle."
她和那个Craigslist上的人约好在一家CVS药店见面。警察先进入药店。然后凯蒂在手机里问他：“你穿着什么衣服？”这样她能认出他。她告诉他：“好了，我在化妆品货架这边。”
I'm like, "Oh, I'm by the CoverGirl makeup." He starts walking down the aisle, I guess, and he says, "Oh, I still don't see you." And at that point, I hear, "Hands up! You're under arrest."
我说：“哦，我就在CoverGirl化妆品旁边。”我猜他开始走过过道，他说：“哦，我还是没看见你。”就在那时，我听到：“举起手来！你被捕了。”
And the same detectives who were brushing me off the entire ride out there then are walking over to the car with the video camera in hand, high-fiving each other. And I hear them say, like, "That was some real police work. Great detective work."
然后那些在去路上一路敷衍我的侦探们，手里拿着摄像机向车走来，互相击掌。我听到他们说：“那真是地道的警察工作。出色的侦探工作。”
The police could not be more surprised to be making this arrest. And to be fair, as Miles pointed out, it's crazy that it worked.
警察们对于能完成这次抓捕感到无比惊讶。公平地说，正如迈尔斯所指出的，这事能成简直是疯了。
There's so many different stages where the criminal should've bailed out, you know? Like the fact that she comes up the story about, I need the warranty. He calls her back. He makes the effort to call her back and said, "Didn't you need a serial number for the warranty?" It's like, what? Like, I can't believe that he's playing along with it.
犯罪分子本该在很多不同阶段就放弃的，不是吗？比如她编出那个需要保修单的故事。他回电了，他特意回电说：“你不需要序列号来保修吗？”这简直是，什么？我不敢相信他竟然顺着她的谎言演戏。
Honestly, like, you don't get that level of service from real stores.
老实说，你在真正的商店里都享受不到这种级别的服务。
[LAUGHS] You don't.
[笑] 确实没有。
See, but that's the whole thing, is that she's an amateur sleuth, but he's also an amateur criminal.
看，这就是重点，她是个业余侦探，但他也是个业余罪犯。
Right.
没错。
And this is the moment where they meet up.
这就是他们相遇的时刻。
Right. So there'd be no way a detective would ever spend the amount of time that it would take to concoct this ruse to go after this camera. So the only way that it could ever be solved would be if two amateurs met up.
对。所以侦探永远不可能花那么多时间去设计一个这种圈套来追回摄像机。所以这件事唯一能解决的途径就是两个业余选手碰上了。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, amateurs-- the fact that they are not professionals, that they do not play by the book, that they have time on their hands to try whatever makes it possible for them to accomplish things the pros simply never will. We have three stories, including amateurs stepping into one of the most powerful jobs in the world and one of the most commonplace. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的主题是——业余爱好者。他们不是专业人士，他们不按套路出牌，他们有充裕的时间去尝试任何事，这使得他们能够完成专业人士永远无法完成的事情。我们有三个故事，包括业余爱好者走上世界上最有权力的职位，以及处理最平凡的事情。请继续收听。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
Act One, "Theater of War." Sometimes a big professional outfit that is great at one thing takes on a task at which it has no experience at all, and really no special aptitude for in any way. It is a rank amateur. Jack Hitt has this example.
第一幕，“战争戏剧”。有时候，一个在某一方面很出色的专业大机构，会去承担一项他们完全没有经验，也没有任何特殊天赋的任务。这简直是一个超级票友。杰克·希特带来了这个例子。
Back when the first President Bush was in office, Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait. And for the first time since Vietnam, really, America returned to the battlefield. Derrick Brown felt called. And so he wound up at Fort Bragg, North Carolina, one of the largest military bases in the world. Back then, about 40,000 soldiers-- most famously, the 82nd Airborne and other Ready Units that can be deployed in 18 hours.
老布什总统在任时，萨达姆·侯赛因入侵了科威特。自越南战争以来，美国首次真正回到了战场。德里克·布朗感到了一种使命感。于是他来到了北卡罗来纳州的布拉格堡，这是世界上最大的军事基地之一。当时那里有大约4万名士兵，最著名的是第82空降师和其他能在18小时内完成部署的快速反应部队。
Fort Bragg is America's waiting room for war. When Derrick first arrived, he was trained as a paratrooper.
布拉格堡是美国的战前候车室。德里克刚到那里时，接受的是伞兵训练。
You know, you'd wake up at 5:00 in the morning. Then you would deploy out to the field. You'd do a jump from 800 feet. I was an artilleryman, so they'd throw the tanks out of the planes. Then they'd throw us out of the planes. So you'd do these mock war exercises where people would try and attack you and kill you, and you'd be out in the cold, and you'd be digging more foxholes, and just seeing how ground down you could possibly be, so that when the time comes for war, your body and mind have been pushed as far as possible.
你知道，你早上5点起床，然后部署到野外。你要从800英尺高空跳伞。我是炮兵，所以他们会把坦克从飞机上扔下去，然后把我们也扔下去。你要进行模拟战争演习，有人会试图攻击你并杀了你，你在寒冷中挖掘更多的散兵坑，看看你的身体和精神到底能承受多大压力，这样当战争真正到来时，你的身心就已经被推到了极限。
Every once in a while, there'd be something else-- a volunteer duty.
偶尔，还会有其他的事情——志愿任务。
I remember the captain of our unit, he said he had this strange detail, which was we had to mandatorily send one soldier from our battery to be a part of this musical. And it would last several weeks. You wouldn't have to do any field duty, but you would have to sing and dance.
我记得我们连的连长说他有个奇怪的任务，我们要强制从连队派出一名士兵去参加一个音乐剧。要持续好几个星期。你不需要执行任何野外任务，但你得唱歌跳舞。
And everyone thought he was joking. And I raised my hand. And he said, "Great. Report to the Fort Bragg theater today."
大家都以为他在开玩笑。但我举手了。他说：“太棒了，今天就向布拉格堡剧院报到。”
Were you the only person who volunteered for this?
你是唯一一个自愿参加的人吗？
I was the only person who volunteered. And they had me sit in this room, and this director first had everyone audition. And he asked if I knew of any songs that I could sing from any musicals. And I said, "Not at all."
我是唯一自愿的。他们让我坐在房间里，导演先让大家试镜。他问我是否知道任何能从音乐剧中唱的歌。我说：“完全不知道。”
I had never sang or danced in my life, except while running and singing cadences and Jody calls in the military. And he said, "Well, just sing me something." And I remember singing "Even Flow," by Pearl Jam.
我这辈子从来没唱过歌跳过舞，除了在军队里跑步时唱的军号和口令。他说：“好吧，就唱点什么吧。”我记得我唱了珍珠果酱乐队的《Even Flow》。
Can you give a couple of lines?
你能唱两句吗？
It's-- [LAUGHS]
那是—— [笑]
(SINGING) Even--
(唱) Even——
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
(SINGING)   Even flow, thoughts arrive like--
(唱) Even flow, thoughts arrive like——
I think I was just impersonating Eddie Vedder the whole time.
我想我当时一直在模仿埃迪·维达。
[LAUGHS] OK.
[笑] 好吧。
And somehow they thought it was good enough. And it turns out that no one was turned away.
不知怎么地，他们觉得还不错。结果证明，没有一个人被拒绝。
In rehearsals, Derrick quickly got a sense that something different was going on here. This was not just your average musical revue.
在排练中，德里克很快感觉到这里正在进行一些不同的事情。这不仅仅是普通的音乐剧表演。
What kind of dancing are you doing?
你们在跳什么舞？
It's march dancing. I don't know if you've seen it, but it is the director's idea to combine the honor and discipline of military movements with the bravado and panache of Broadway movements.
这是队列舞。我不知道你有没有见过，但这是导演的想法，结合了军队动作的荣誉和纪律，以及百老汇动作的浮夸和华丽。
But the thing Derrick remembers most, more than 20 years later, was not the song-and-dance numbers. It was the stuff in between. There were short films projected on the screen above the performers. And they were opposite of lighthearted entertainment-- grim testimonials about soldiers who'd died. Not in combat, but drunk driving and in other accidents near the base, all done in a dark bluntness one rarely sees outside driver's ed movies.
但德里克在20多年后印象最深的，不是歌舞表演，而是中间穿插的内容。屏幕上播放着简短的电影。它们与轻松的娱乐截然相反——那是关于士兵死去的悲惨证言。不是死于战斗，而是死于酒驾或基地附近的事故，所有的处理方式都有一种在驾驶课程电影之外很少见到的阴郁直白。
We'd go from show tune to a video on the screen of a fellow soldier that they'd interviewed talking about how one of their fellow soldiers, their friend, died. And then-- uh-oh, surprise! We would sing a show tune.
我们要从表演曲目转到屏幕上关于采访士兵讲述他们朋友是如何死去的视频。然后——哦哦，惊喜！我们还要接着唱表演曲目。
And it was this progression of dance, sad video, sing a bit, sad video. And then some guys come rappelling out of the ceiling for the closing number at the end of the hour, for the final chance to cheer everyone up so they leave feeling inspired. It was insane.
这就是那种舞蹈、悲伤视频、唱歌、悲伤视频的循环。然后演出结束前的一小时，一些家伙从天花板速降下来作为压轴，最后一次试图让大家振作起来，这样他们离开时会感到受鼓舞。这太疯狂了。
We would have discussions backstage, which is what the-- what are we doing? Why are we doing this? How did this-- how did this thing even come to be?
我们在后台会讨论，这到底是——我们在做什么？为什么我们要这么做？这到底是怎么产生的？
Excellent questions. How did one of the most straitlaced, no-nonsense institutions in the entire country, the US Army, end up producing this piece of Dada musical theater? I wanted answers. So I went straight up the chain of command.
非常好的问题。这个全国最古板、最讲求实效的机构——美国陆军，到底是怎么制作出这种达达主义音乐剧的？我想要答案。所以我直接去询问了指挥链。
Yes, I'm General Carl Stiner, US Army, retired. And I was the Commander of the 82nd Airborne Division during 1987 and 1988.
是的，我是卡尔·斯泰纳将军，美国陆军退役。1987年到1988年期间，我是第82空降师的指挥官。
General Stiner was at Fort Bragg. And he confirmed that yes, for a while in the '70s, '80s, and early '90s, there was this annual show which the entire base was required to attend. So there were three or four performances a day for a week or so during the Christmas season, which is when accidental deaths spiked.
斯泰纳将军当时就在布拉格堡。他证实，是的，在70年代、80年代和90年代初，确实有这样一个年度演出，整个基地的人都被要求参加。所以在圣诞季期间，大概一周时间，每天会有三到四场演出，那段时间正是意外死亡率飙升的时候。
We realized that we were having more casualties from off-duty activities-- mainly motorcycles-- than from thousands of parachute jumps and heavy equipment drops. You know, we just needed to do something about it.
我们意识到，我们因非值勤活动——主要是摩托车——造成的伤亡比数千次跳伞和重装备空投造成的伤亡还要多。你知道，我们就是得为此做点什么。
Stiner told me that some years, for every death of a soldier during training exercises, there were almost 10 killed getting drunk and driving crazy. Wartime deaths, we all know about, and after-war PTSD. But this was a whole other kind of statistic-- pre-combat deaths-- which come when tens of thousands of teenagers anxiously awaiting war get pumped up jumping out of planes and firing heavy artillery. How could some beer and, say, a motorcycle possibly affect them?
斯泰纳告诉我，有些年份，每有一名士兵死于训练演习，几乎就有10个人死于酗酒和疯狂驾驶。战争死亡我们都知道，还有战后创伤后应激障碍。但这完全是另一种统计数据——战斗前死亡——这些发生在上万名焦急等待战争的年轻人身上，他们通过跳伞和发射重型火炮来释放压力。几瓶啤酒，或者说，一辆摩托车怎么可能影响到他们？
Originally, the base had ordered mandatory safety lectures. But the soldiers just slept through them. So the United States Defense Department, the greatest fighting force ever to march on the planet, decided they would try show tunes. And that's the origin of what came to be called The Soldier Safety Show.
最初，基地强制执行安全讲座，但士兵们在讲座上只会睡觉。所以美国国防部，这支地球上行军的最伟大战斗力量，决定尝试音乐剧。这就是后来被称为“士兵安全秀”的起源。
I interviewed a dozen veterans from this era, and they all remember the weird mash-up of gut-wrenching testimonials and cheery eye-high leg kicks. They all said, "You had to see it to believe it." And I wanted to believe it.
我采访了那个时代的十几名退伍军人，他们都记得那种揪心的证言和欢快的踢腿动作之间怪异的融合。他们都说：“你得亲眼见过才敢相信。”而我真的想见识一下。
When I called Stiner, he told me that he had a videotape of one of the shows.
当我联系斯泰纳时，他告诉我他有一盘演出录像带。
You know, I had a VCR of it. But age caused the thing to self-destruct. You couldn't even tell what it was, the pictures and so on. And so we struck out.
你知道，我曾经有一盘录像带。但年代久远让它自我毁坏了。你甚至看不出那是什么，画面等等都糊了。所以我们没戏了。
I won't bore you with the details. But finding a videotape literally took months. The public school library had a set of Soldier Safety Shows, but not long before I called, they went full-on digital and junked all their old school audiovisual stuff. A Freedom of Information request came up completely dry.
我不会详细描述过程。但找到一盘录像带确实花费了数月时间。公立学校图书馆曾经有一套士兵安全秀，但在我联系前不久，他们全面数字化，把所有的旧视听资料都报废了。信息自由法案的请求也完全无果。
Finally, I happened upon Gudron Blackmon, still working at Bragg, who called back to say she had an old box at home and, in it, a tape. The label read, "1989 Soldier Safety Show-- Life is Worth Living."
最后，我偶然联系到了古德隆·布莱克蒙，她还在布拉格堡工作，她回电说家里有一个旧箱子，里面有一盘带子。标签上写着：“1989士兵安全秀——生命值得活下去。”
(SINGING)  This road of life we travel, it can take us many ways.
(唱) 我们行走的生命之路，可以带我们去很多地方。
Early on, we see a folk guitarist seated onstage, plucking out a sad melody.
在早期，我们看到一位民谣吉他手坐在舞台上，弹奏着悲伤的旋律。
(SINGING)  But for all of these young soldiers whose lives had just begun--
(唱) 但是对于所有这些生命刚刚开始的年轻士兵来说——
Above him, on a screen, is a general. It's actually General Stiner himself entering a cemetery. And he starts talking about accidental deaths on base.
在他上方，屏幕上是一位将军。那实际上是斯泰纳将军本人正在进入公墓。他开始谈论基地里的意外死亡。
When a soldier is killed, I feel terrible. I get a sickening feeling, a feeling of failure. We lost 26 this year, and it's terrible. Charles. Adam. James.
当一名士兵死去时，我感到很糟糕。我有一种令人作呕的感觉，一种失败感。今年我们失去了26人，这很可怕。查尔斯。亚当。詹姆斯。
General Stiner occasionally kneels down, and, at one point, removes his beret--
斯泰纳将军偶尔会跪下，并在某一点摘下贝雷帽——
Unnecessary.
没必要。
And talks directly to a tombstone.
直接对着墓碑讲话。
We tried with you, Tosher, and we failed. Perhaps we could have done a little better if your friends had been more forthcoming to us with your problems. You were a great soldier. And we loved you. How many new graves next year? What do I have to do to stop these unnecessary and needless deaths?
我们尝试过帮助你，托舍尔，但我们失败了。也许如果你的朋友们能多向我们反映你的问题，我们会做得更好一点。你是个伟大的士兵，我们爱你。明年还会有多少新坟墓？我该怎么做才能停止这些不必要和无谓的死亡？
[JAZZ BAND MUSIC PLAYING]
[爵士乐队音乐]
The lights come up on a stage packed with 30 or 40 men and women in fancy dress doing some tap dance moves with lots of spirit fingers and jazz hands. It's a tribute to everyone who fought in World War II. And these absurd smash-ups just keep happening for the rest of the show, just like all the soldiers told me.
舞台灯光亮起，上面挤满了30或40名穿着华丽服装的男女，他们跳着踢踏舞，配合着夸张的手势和爵士舞姿。这是对所有二战老兵的致敬。这种荒谬的冲突在演出剩下的时间里一直持续，就像所有士兵告诉我的那样。
So who came up with this idea? Who was the mastermind of Operation Schlock and Awe? His name was Lee Yopp. And his journey to theater was not one anyone might predict.
那么是谁想出这个主意的？“震惊与敬畏行动”的策划者是谁？他的名字叫李·约普。他走上戏剧之路的历程没有人能预见到。
He had-- he had no personal taste. He ate overdone meat, and he wore polyester suits. I mean, he didn't care what he wore.
他——他没有个人品味。他吃过熟的肉，穿着聚酯西装。我是说，他不在乎自己穿什么。
That's Bo Thorp, a local North Carolina actress who was frequently cast in these shows. Yopp died back in 2006. I talked to other actors, too, and they all reacted like Reese Brown, a paratrooper from the '90s.
那是博·索普，一位经常被选入这些演出的北卡罗来纳州女演员。约普在2006年去世了。我也和其他演员谈过，他们都像90年代的伞兵里斯·布朗一样反应。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
[LAUGHS] See, everyone laughs when I ask about Lee.
[笑] 看，我问起李的时候大家都笑了。
No, because it's funny, because I haven't thought about him in years. But just to think about just some of the things that he said, every word he used, every enunciation he used, every colorful description he used, was filled with 10 words that didn't need to be there. [LAUGHS] He didn't say, "I'm going to the store." "I'm traversing down to--" You know, it was one of those things.
不，因为这很有趣，因为我已经很多年没想过他了。但想到他说的每一句话，他用的每一个措辞，每一个夸张的描述，里面都充斥着10个本不需要在那里的词。[笑] 他不会说“我去商店”。他说“我将穿行前往……”你知道，就是这类事情。
But he had no room at all for shyness on stage. He made it a point of saying that if you're going to fail, please fail loudly.
但他舞台上根本容不得羞怯。他强调如果注定要失败，请大声地失败。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
"Please fail loudly, and sing it as though your life depended on it." [CHUCKLES] It's odd, because I'd never met anyone like him, prior to this point. It's like, where did this guy come from?
“请大声地失败，像生命依赖于它一样去歌唱。” [轻笑] 这很奇怪，因为在此之前我从没见过像他这样的人。就像，这家伙是从哪儿冒出来的？
He was a high school football coach.
他是个高中橄榄球教练。
That's Bo Thorp again.
还是博·索普。
This was in Trenton, New Jersey. And the director of the class play died suddenly, and Lee inherited the class play. And it also happened that he had just broken his leg, so he really couldn't go out on the football field. So that's how he got into the theater.
那是新泽西州的特伦顿。班级戏剧的导演突然去世，李继承了班级戏剧。恰巧那时他刚摔断了腿，所以他真的不能去橄榄球场。这就是他进入戏剧界的经过。
And so he took his A personality football coach approach to life into the theater.
于是他把橄榄球教练的那种A型人格带到了戏剧中。
This is Steve Currie, who long worked as Yopp's stage manager.
这是史蒂夫·库里，曾长期担任约普的舞台监督。
And within a very short period of time, turned this little high school theater program into a major competitive organization that won the National Theater Award for high schools across the nation. And they went on a tour of Germany and Japan with this production he put together. And it just was like he was bit, you know? He couldn't get enough of it.
在很短的时间内，他把这个小高中的戏剧项目变成了一个重大的竞争组织，赢得了全美高中的全国戏剧奖。他们还带着他制作的这部剧去德国和日本巡演。就好像他上瘾了一样，你知道吗？他沉迷其中无法自拔。
Lee Yopp wound up as the chief director of the Bucks County Playhouse outside Trenton, New Jersey, which is one of the farm teams for lots of Broadway shows. Yopp gave Bucks County his all, spending lavishly, even putting his own money into the shows.
李·约普最终成为了新泽西州特伦顿郊外巴克斯县剧场的首席导演，那是许多百老汇演出的训练基地之一。约普为巴克斯县倾尽所有，大肆挥霍，甚至把自己的钱投进演出中。
Lee had just taken a second mortgage on his house in New Jersey to use as an investment in a show called Smile, Smile, Smile . The reviews came out. It was Smile , Smile , Smile , it was supposed to be funny. It wasn't, it wasn't, it wasn't. Period. It was one of the shortest theater reviews in the history of musical theater.
李刚刚给他在新泽西州的房子办了二抵，投资了一部叫《微笑，微笑，微笑》的剧。评论出来了。它应该很有趣。结果它不，它不，它不。句号。这是音乐剧历史上最短的剧评之一。
Currie told me that Yopp bankrupted the Bucks County Playhouse-- and himself, his personal finances so wrecked, he couldn't get a phone in his own name. But then fate stepped in when Yopp bumped into an old Army buddy at an airport who was looking for someone who could direct theater at Fort Bragg.
库里告诉我，约普搞破产了巴克斯县剧场——还有他自己，他的个人财务状况彻底崩溃，连自己的名字都不能用来开电话账户。但后来命运降临，约普在机场偶遇了一位老战友，那人正在寻找能为布拉格堡执导戏剧的人。
They were thrilled to death with this man who brought theatricality to the Army, the last place in the world that you would think.
他们对这个把戏剧性带入陆军的人感到无比兴奋，这是你认为世界上最后一个会出现戏剧的地方。
The one financial backer--
那个唯一的投资人——
That-- right, that could afford him. Right. That could afford him. Exactly.
那个——对了，就是那个付得起他酬劳的人。对了。就是那个付得起他的人。没错。
The Defense Department.
美国国防部。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
Steve Currie, the stage manager, told me that with that money, they built waterfalls and a set for a roller-skating number. Another time, they planted the entire stage in real grass for a park scene with cops on horseback.
舞台监督史蒂夫·库里告诉我，有了那笔钱，他们搭建了瀑布，还有旱冰表演的布景。还有一次，为了一个有骑马警察出现的公园场景，他们在整个舞台上种了真草。
Oh, we had people rappelling from rafters. We had people in parachute rigging flying in over the stage. Cannons and machine guns and muskets, and horses rearing up through the cannon fire. Thompson submachine guns firing.
哦，有人从房梁上速降。有人穿着降落伞装备从舞台上空飞过。大炮、机枪、火枪，还有马匹在炮火中嘶鸣。汤姆森冲锋枪开火。
And these are all going off inside a theater.
这些都是在剧场里发生的。
Oh, yeah. [LAUGHS]
哦，是的。[笑]
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
We would also trigger explosions that we'd set into the stage floor. I would hook up these, like, flash pots. I got-- I got the guy from Special Forces-- he would get me all these, what they call squibs, which are these electronic fuses, and we would create these great explosions. You could never do it today. Fire marshal would shut you down. But we were the Army.
我们还会触发我们在舞台地板里设置的爆炸。我会连接这些类似闪光罐的东西。我让特种部队的人——他会给我弄来所有这些所谓的导爆索，也就是电子引信，我们制造了这些巨大的爆炸。你现在绝对做不到这一点了，消防队长会关掉你的剧场。但我们是陆军。
Wow.
哇。
And what was impressive about it is how I realized that there was no end to Yopp. He had a special and unique way of making the simple more complicated than you could ever imagine it.
令人印象深刻的是我意识到约普没有尽头。他有一种特殊而独特的方法，能让简单的事情变得复杂得超出你的想象。
Let me just take a moment to say how rare this is. I wrote a book about amateurs a few years ago, those dreamers in their garages, fiddling, creating, struggling. What keeps most of them stuck in their garage is lack of funders. Lee Yopp had hundreds of millions of funders-- the taxpayers of the United States.
让我花点时间谈谈这有多罕见。几年前我写了一本关于业余爱好者的书，那些车库里的梦想家，修修补补，创造，奋斗。大多数人被困在车库的原因是缺乏资金支持者。李·约普拥有数以亿计的资助者——美国纳税人。
Everybody I talked to-- especially the cast and crew that were in so many of these shows, the regulars-- all mentioned this one time, one moment that stood out for them. It was 1982. There'd been a terrible car accident, this time involving one of the cast members' kids. Here's actress Bo Thorp.
我交谈过的每个人——尤其是那些经常参与演出的演员和工作人员——都提到了这一个让他们印象深刻的时刻。那是1982年。发生了一起严重的车祸，这次涉及到其中一名演员的孩子。这是女演员博·索普。
My son was nearly killed. I mean, he was coming home from his first football game. He was 14 years old. It was October the 8th.
我儿子差点死了。我的意思是，他从第一场橄榄球比赛回家。他当时14岁。那是10月8日。
And the young girl who was driving her father's car decided to see how fast her daddy's car would come down Sky Drive, which is where we live. He remembers her saying 80. And when she went to put on the brakes, the car went into a skid and then hit a tree. And so he was in a body cast for six months.
开着她父亲车的那个年轻女孩决定看看她爸爸的车在天际路——我们住的地方——能开多快。他记得她说时速是80英里。当她想踩刹车时，车子打滑撞上了一棵树。所以他在全身石膏里躺了六个月。
She says everyone in the show was heartbroken, of course, including Yopp. But Yopp, being Yopp, saw an opportunity.
她说剧组里的每个人当然都心碎了，包括约普。但约普，终究是约普，他看到了一个机会。
He said, "Ah! You know what we can do? You think-- would you let us go up to the hospital? And I'll bring a film crew, and we'll go up to the hospital, and we'll film Clay. And then he can-- and then he can make testimony on the tape."
他说：“啊！你知道我们可以做什么吗？你认为——你愿意让我们去医院吗？我会带一个摄制组去医院，我们去拍克莱。然后他就能——然后他就能在磁带上作证。”
And I said, "Lee, I don't-- I don't know that that's the right thing to do."
我说：“李，我不知道——我不知道那是该做的事。”
"Oh, yeah, absolutely! They'll-- the soldiers will love it. They'll-- they'll understand it.  It'll mean a lot to them."
“哦，是的，绝对！士兵们会喜欢的。他们会——他们会理解的。这对他们意义重大。”
You know, I-- I was really reluctant about it, 'cause I thought that, you know, it was just not very tasteful.
你知道，我——我真的很勉强，因为我觉得，你知道，这不太有品位。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
A few weeks later, there was Bo on stage.
几周后，博出现在舞台上。
My 14-year-old son was in a very serious car accident. It happens like that, you know? There's no warning. It just comes-- boom-- like that. We went up to Clay's hospital room when he was very sick. And he agreed to make this film. I hope you'll pay attention.
我14岁的儿子发生了一起非常严重的交通事故。事情就这样发生了，你知道吗？没有任何预警。就这么——砰——就那样。在他病得很重时，我们去了克莱的病房。他同意制作这部电影。我希望大家关注。
Then, on the big screen, Clay Thorp, 14 years old, lying in a hospital bed, flat on his back, in a full body cast. And Clay jumps right in, looking into the camera as best he can, reliving the accident, calling out the miles per hour as if he were once again flying down that hill.
然后，在大屏幕上，14岁的克莱·索普躺在病床上，平躺着，打着全身石膏。克莱直接看向镜头，尽他所能，重温那场事故，惊叫着时速，仿佛他再次在那山坡上疾驰。
10. 20. 30. 40. 50. I told her to slow down. 60? 70? Oh my god! This is a dream. This can't be happening.
10，20，30，40，50。我叫她慢下来。60？70？天哪！这是场梦。这不可能发生。
Here I am in this place. I'm not normal now. I wish I could get out. I wish I could get out tomorrow.
我竟然在这个地方。我现在不正常了。我希望能出去。我希望明天就能出去。
(SINGING) The sun'll come out, tomorrow. Bet your bottom dollar that tomorrow, there'll be sun.
(唱) 太阳明天会出来。你敢把最后一块钱压在明天，明天会有太阳。
And then beneath the video screen, a young girl comes out on stage.
然后视频屏幕下方，一个年轻女孩走上舞台。
(SINGING)  When I'm stuck with a day that's gray and lonely, I just stick out my chin and grin and say, oh--
(唱) 当我被困在灰暗孤独的一天，我就伸出下巴咧嘴笑说，哦——
And-- and do you think this had-- I mean, how-- how effective was this with the soldiers?
而且——你认为这有——我是说，这——这对士兵们有多有效？
Amazing. Absolutely amazing. Because these are 18-year-old boys.
惊人。绝对惊人。因为这些是18岁的男孩。
And when you're 18 years old and you're a butch kind of male, your life is gonna go on forever. And you're-- you're special. You're gonna last forever. And you can do whatever you want to do. And-- and if you die, so what? And Lee had a way of understanding that. He would do everything he could to prove to them or to show them the value of life and how short it is, and how quickly it goes by.
当你18岁，是个强壮的男人时，你的生活会永远持续下去。你很特别，你会永远存在。你可以做任何你想做的事。而且——如果你死了，那又怎样？李有办法理解这一点。他会尽一切努力向他们证明或者向他们展示生命的价值，它是多么短暂，消逝得多么快。
(SINGING)  The sun'll come out tomorrow. Bet your bottom dollar that tomorrow, there'll be--
(唱) 太阳明天会出来。你敢把最后一块钱压在明天，明天会有——
You know what this is? It's the lecture I gave my teenage daughter a few nights ago when I handed her the car keys. "Drive carefully. Buckle up. Please don't be an idiot." Every parent tries to come up with some way to say this to their kid. Lee Yopp had to crack that code for 40,000 of them.
你知道这是什么吗？这是几天前我把车钥匙交给十几岁的女儿时，我给她的演讲。“小心驾驶。系好安全带。请别犯傻。”每个父母都试图想出某种方式告诉孩子这些。李·约普不得不为4万个孩子破解了这个密码。
And you know what? It worked. After the Soldier Safety Show started, the average number of deaths at the base dropped by a third.
而且你知道吗？它成功了。在士兵安全秀开始后，基地里的死亡人数平均下降了三分之一。
(SINGING) Tomorrow, tomorrow, I love ya, tomorrow. You're only--
(唱) 明天，明天，我爱你，明天。你只是——
At the end of every show, one of Yopp's actors always came out on the stage to give the final safety lecture.
在每场演出结束时，约普的演员之一总是会来到舞台上进行最后的安全演讲。
We need your help. And we ask that each and every one of you join with us to make this pledge to always, always wear your safety belts.
我们需要你的帮助。我们要求在座的每一位与我们一起做出承诺，永远、永远系好你们的安全带。
The speaker asks everyone who believes in safety to stand and take the pledge. These are soldiers, and they follow orders.
演讲者要求所有相信安全的人站起来做出承诺。他们是士兵，他们服从命令。
Please--
请——
So naturally, up jumps everyone in the audience. And then the cast floods the stage for the final number and Yopp's last brilliant contribution to musical theater-- a guaranteed standing ovation at the end of every show.
所以观众中所有人都自然地跳了起来。然后演员们涌上舞台进行最后的演出，这是约普对音乐剧最后也是最辉煌的贡献——每场演出结束时保证起立鼓掌。
(SINGING)  Everyone will sing!
(唱) 每个人都要唱！
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Jack Hitt. He's the author of several books, including the one that he mentioned in this story. It is called Bunch of Amateurs . It recently came out in paperback.
杰克·希特。他是几本书的作者，包括他在这个故事中提到的那本。书名叫《业余爱好者》。最近出了平装本。
Coming up, babies having babies-- robot babies, specifically. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，婴儿生婴儿——特别是机器人婴儿。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时为你播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- "Amateur Hour," stories of how amateurs can accomplish things that the pros cannot. That is, when they are not crashing and burning completely.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来不同种类的故事。今天的节目——“业余时间”，关于业余爱好者如何能够完成专业人士无法做到的事情的故事。当然，前提是他们没有彻底搞砸。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "What to Expect When You're Expecting a Robot."
现在是节目的第二幕。第二幕，“当你期待一个机器人宝宝时会发生什么”。
There's this thing that a lot of kids have to do in health class. Maybe you did this when you were in high school. The idea is to give students a taste of what it is like to be responsible for an infant-- and kind of what a pain in the ass it is, actually. And they do this by making the kids carry around an egg-- or sometimes it's, like, a sack of flour-- for a couple days. Supposedly this jolt of reality helps prevent teen pregnancies. Which, you know, is a lot to ask of an egg.
很多孩子在健康课上必须做这件事。也许你在高中时也做过。目的是让学生体会作为婴儿的责任，以及这实际上是多么麻烦。他们通过让孩子带着一个鸡蛋——或者有时是一袋面粉——走来走去几天来实现。据说这种现实的冲击有助于防止青少年怀孕。这，你知道，对一个鸡蛋来说要求太高了。
So these days, some schools are using these robotic babies. These are plastic dolls  with electronics inside which make them cry randomly, all day and night. Their sleeping, eating, and pooping patterns are based on logs kept by real parents about real babies. The babies cost over $600 each. Hillary Frank went out to find out if amateur parenthood is more intense and realistic with these high-tech crybabies.
所以现在，一些学校开始使用这些机器人婴儿。这些是带有电子装置的塑料玩偶，整天整夜随机啼哭。它们的睡眠、饮食和排便模式都是基于真实父母记录的真实婴儿数据。每个婴儿的价格超过600美元。希拉里·弗兰克去调查这种业余父母身份是否通过这些高科技哭闹娃娃变得更加强烈和逼真。
The first time I saw a robotic baby was at my local pharmacy. It was one of those old-timey places with a candy counter and surgical supplies and a large selection of scented candles. One day I was in the store, and I heard this teenage girl behind me say, "My god, this baby is so heavy." She had a car seat slung over her shoulder like a purse. For a second I thought the plastic baby inside it was real.
我第一次见到机器人婴儿是在当地的药店。那是一家古色古香的商店，有糖果柜台、医疗用品和各式香薰蜡烛。有一天我在店里，听到身后有个十几岁的女孩说：“天哪，这婴儿太重了。”她把汽车安全座椅像钱包一样斜背在肩上。那一秒我以为里面的塑料婴儿是真的。
"The real ones are heavier," I told her. She groaned and whipped the car seat over to her other shoulder. At the time I had a three-year-old, and I was dying to know if this girl's experience with the plastic baby was anything remotely like my experience with my flesh-and-blood baby.
“真的婴儿更重，”我告诉她。她呻吟着，把安全座椅甩到另一侧肩膀上。当时我有一个三岁的孩子，我很想知道这个女孩对塑料婴儿的经历是否与我对自己血肉之躯宝宝的经历有任何相似之处。
The girl told me she went to Glen Ridge High. Glen Ridge is the town next to mine in New Jersey. So I called the school and asked if they'd let me hang out the next time the girls got the babies.
那个女孩告诉我她去的是格伦里奇高中。格伦里奇就在我居住的新泽西州小镇隔壁。所以我打电话给学校，询问下次女孩们领取婴儿时是否允许我跟着看看。
[WAILING]
[啼哭]
Oh, and don't forget to support her neck when you pick her up out of the car seat. OK?
哦，别忘了在把她从安全座椅里抱出来时支撑她的脖子。好吗？
Ms. Hogan, the health teacher, is setting up two girls with their babies. The robot babies are so expensive that the school only has 10 of them, so the students take turns with them for two solid days of pretend parenting. In the class I visited, the students on deck were Rachel--
健康老师霍根女士正在为两个女孩准备她们的宝宝。机器人婴儿太贵了，所以学校只有10个，学生们轮流照顾，进行为期两天的模拟育儿。在我访问的班级里，当值的学生是瑞秋——
Let's kick it. I'm excited. My baby's here.
开始吧。我很兴奋，我的宝宝在这儿。
And Paige.
还有佩奇。
I don't know why I'm so nervous about this baby, but it-- it'll be good.
我不知道为什么我对这个宝宝这么紧张，但它——它会很有意义。
My producer Joanna and I followed them with their babies over the next 48 hours. Rachel and Paige are friends, but they're about as different as two 17-year-olds can be. We'll start with Paige.
我的制作人乔安娜和我接下来48小时一直跟着她们。瑞秋和佩奇是朋友，但她们是17岁女孩中截然不同的两个典型。我们先从佩奇开始。
Paige is brimming with maternal affection for her fake baby. She pulls a flowered onesie out of her bookbag and shows it to Joanna.
佩奇对假宝宝充满了母爱。她从书包里掏出一件花边连体衣给乔安娜看。
I brought clothes for her.
我为她带了衣服。
Wait, are these your baby clothes?
等等，这些是你小时候的衣服吗？
Well, I think some of them are, and my mom saved them. And then I used them for when I used to play baby dolls.
嗯，我想有一些是，我妈妈保存着它们。然后我以前玩洋娃娃的时候用过它们。
Just a note here about Paige's voice. I've never heard anyone talk like her before. She's not whispering or anything. This is just the way she sounds.
关于佩奇的声音，这里说明一下。我从没听过任何人像她那样说话。她没有窃窃私语，这只是她说话的方式。
You're really, like, going for the full immersion.
你真的是全情投入了。
I am.   I am. Because I-- I was so excited to get a baby. So I know it'll be so much fun. It'll be hard. But it'll be fun!
是的，我是。因为我——我得到宝宝太兴奋了。所以我知道这会很有趣。这会很难，但会很有趣！
To be clear, there was no need to bring baby clothes. The doll comes with its own outfit.
说明一下，根本不需要带婴儿衣服。玩偶自带一套服装。
Paige is a devout Christian. She wears a purity ring.
佩奇是虔诚的基督徒，她带着一枚贞操戒指。
And I made a promise that I will not ever give myself away before I'm married. 'Cause I think it's one of the worst mistakes somebody could do.
而且我许诺过，在结婚前我绝不会把第一次交出去。因为我认为那是人能犯的最糟糕的错误之一。
So that's Paige. Now here's Rachel.
这就是佩奇。现在是瑞秋。
I don't think that losing your virginity is giving yourself away.
我不认为失去童贞就是把什么交出去。
Rachel is  the quintessential theater kid. She describes herself as liberal and bisexual. She's never had sex with anyone, but she keeps a good luck condom in her drawer, just in case.
瑞秋是典型的戏剧社孩子。她自称是自由派和双性恋者。她从未与任何人发生过性关系，但她在抽屉里放着一个护身避孕套，以防万一。
Just-- it's just in my room.  I know it's there. Like, I went on a trip somewhere once, like by myself. And I just brought it, even though I knew I wouldn't use it. But it's just, like, for good luck.
只是——它就在我的房间里。我知道它在那儿。有次我自己去旅行时，我也带着它，尽管我知道我不会用。但这就像是为了好运。
Rachel thinks she wants to wait until her 30s to have kids. She did not bring in baby clothes today for her robot baby. She thinks this whole baby thing will just make for a fun story, like the time she joined the boys' wrestling team and wound up puking in the locker room.
瑞秋认为她想等到30多岁再生孩子。她今天没有给她的机器人宝宝带任何衣服。她认为整个照顾宝宝的事情只会成为一个有趣的故事，就像她有次参加了男子摔跤队，最后在更衣室呕吐了一样。
I've been more excited about the back story than anything else. Like, I need to find-- who's the father? I need to figure it out. Was it left on my doorstep?
我对背景故事比什么都兴奋。比如，我需要找到——爸爸是谁？我需要想出来。它是被遗弃在我家门口吗？
The girls take their babies. Each is in a car seat. Each looks like a real baby-- except plastic, with a huge speaker on its chest, a vacant stare. Their lips are always pursed for feeding. And somehow, they always look a little pissed off.
女孩们领到了她们的宝宝。每个都在安全座椅里。每个看起来都像真正的婴儿——除了是塑料做的，胸口有一个巨大的扬声器，眼神空洞。嘴唇永远噘着等待进食。而且不知怎么地，看起来总有点气呼呼的。
Paige and Rachel head to class. Their first big challenge--
佩奇和瑞秋去上课了。她们的第一个大挑战——
Do you know how much blood you're giving?
你知道你要献多少血吗？
Today is the blood drive at Glen Ridge High.
今天是格伦里奇高中的献血日。
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
Let me take my gloves off.
让我先把手套脱了。
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
Rachel is laid out flat on a table with a tourniquet around her arm. Her baby is on the floor, behind her head, in the car seat. The lab tech says--
瑞秋平躺在桌子上，手臂上缠着止血带。她的宝宝在车座里，在地板上，在她的头后方。实验技术员说——
You're not allowed to give her the baby?
你不允许去管宝宝吗？
She can't give Rachel the baby.
她不能去管瑞秋的宝宝。
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
I don't like this.  I want to take care of my baby. I don't like that sound.
我不喜欢这样，我想照顾我的宝宝。我不喜欢那个声音。
If those cries sound disturbingly real, it's because they're recordings of actual babies crying.
如果那些哭声听起来如此真实，那是因为它们是真实婴儿哭声的录音。
[CRYING LOUDLY]
[大声啼哭]
Oh, the baby really wants me now.
哦，宝宝现在真的很需要我。
And if Rachel could get to her baby, here is how she would get it to stop crying.
如果瑞秋能接近她的宝宝，这就是她让它停止哭泣的方法。
It has to be her. It can't be someone else. She's being graded on this. So she's wearing a wristband that she swipes over the baby.
必须是她。不能是别人，她因为这个被评分。所以她戴着一个腕带，在宝宝身上刷一下。
[DIGITAL BEEP]
[数码哔哔声]
That identifies her as the mother. Next, she'd have to figure out why the baby is crying. It could need one of four things-- burping, rocking, diapering, or feeding. To feed it, you hold a fake bottle by the baby's lips, and if she's hungry, she goes like this.
那确认了她是母亲。接下来，她得弄清楚为什么宝宝在哭。它可能需要四件事中的一件——拍嗝、摇晃、换尿布或喂食。要喂它，你把假奶瓶举到宝宝嘴边，如果她饿了，她会这样。
[GULPING] [COOS]
[吞咽声] [咕咕声]
When she's full, she goes like this.
当她吃饱了，她会这样。
[COOS HAPPILY]
[快乐地咕咕声]
You have only two minutes to get it right. If you don't, you lose points. If you don't support the baby's neck? More points off.
你只有两分钟时间做对。如果做不对，你会扣分。如果没有支撑住宝宝的脖子？更多扣分。
So all the time Rachel's on the blood donor table, she's losing points. The lab tech holds Rachel's arm, pushes the needle into her vein.
所以瑞秋躺在献血台上的时候，她一直在扣分。技术员握着瑞秋的手臂，把针头推进她的静脉。
Ow, ow, ow! It really hurts now. It hurts more now. Ow, ow, ow. OK.
哎哟，哎哟，哎哟！真的很疼。现在更疼了。哎哟，哎哟，哎哟。好吧。
Then, like any stressed-out drama geek--
然后，像任何压力巨大的戏剧怪胎一样——
[SINGS OPERATICALLY]
[歌剧式吟唱]
[CRYING LOUDLY]
[大声啼哭]
Rachel bursts into song. Opera.
瑞秋突然唱起了歌。歌剧。
[SINGS OPERATICALLY]
[歌剧式吟唱]
Are-- are you singing because of the pain, or because you don't want to hear the baby crying?
你是——你是唱歌是因为疼痛，还是因为不想听到宝宝的哭声？
It's a little bit of both. Mostly because of the pain. I'm sorry, Baby!
两者都有一点。主要是因为疼痛。对不起，宝宝！
Meanwhile, Paige's baby seems to need attention constantly. She'll feed it or rock it and it'll stop crying, but then start up again four minutes later. Then five minutes after that. Then another seven minutes after that.
与此同时，佩奇的宝宝似乎需要不断地关注。她会喂它或摇晃它，它会停止哭泣，但在四分钟后又开始了。然后五分钟后。然后再过七分钟后。
I think I've kind of learned already-- it's only an hour and a half into it. I've definitely learned this baby, it's kind of like a normal baby, but not, 'cause it-- I think a normal baby is not this needy.
我想我已经学到了一些——距离刚开始才一个半小时。我绝对学到了这个宝宝，它有点像正常的婴儿，但又不完全是，因为它——我想正常的婴儿不会这么粘人。
Of course, a human baby is way more needy. But, you know. Amateurs.
当然，真实的人类婴儿更粘人。但，你知道的。业余爱好者。
Joanna and I follow Paige and Rachel through the rest of their classes. The babies wail through lectures, through debates--
乔安娜和我跟着佩奇和瑞秋上完了剩下的课。婴儿们在讲座中、在辩论中尖叫——
OK, so what else--
好的，还有什么——
In one class, there are four babies going off.
在一节课上，有四个婴儿同时响了起来。
This is the most babyful class I've gone to so far.
这是我到目前为止去过的最“婴儿化”的班级。
Which makes it feel more like a nursery than a school.
这让它感觉更像托儿所而不是学校。
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
While taking a test, Rachel discovers a clever workaround. She props the bottle up in the car seat and basically has the baby feed itself.
在考试时，瑞秋发现了一个巧妙的解决方法。她把奶瓶支在安全座椅上，基本上让婴儿自己喂自己。
Some teachers are amused. Others aren't. The girls are especially nervous about bringing the babies to play rehearsal.
有些老师觉得很有趣，有些则不然。女孩们特别担心把宝宝带到排练场。
All right, listen up!
好了，听着！
They tell me the director's a little shouty.
她们告诉我导演有点爱吼人。
Hello-ooo-oo-oo. Hello!
喂——呜——呜。喂！
Shhh!
嘘！
We are going to begin.
我们要开始了。
Woo!
呜！
The show is Dead Man Walking , a stage version of the film. Both girls are in the play, and they both play mothers. Rachel is the mother of the murderer.
这部剧是《死囚漫步》，电影的舞台版。两个女孩都在剧中，她们都扮演母亲。瑞秋扮演杀手的母亲。
(SINGING)  And I feel so--
(唱) 我感到如此——
Paige is the mother  of the nun.
佩奇扮演修女的母亲。
(SINGING)  Will grow to hate me.
(唱) 会变得恨我。
Paige is standing on a raised platform at the back of the stage. She's swaying a little, looking up at the spotlight as she sings. Then, just as she feared--
佩奇站在舞台后面一个升起的平台上。她随着歌声摇晃着，抬头看着聚光灯。然后，正如她所担心的——
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
From backstage, her baby starts crying. Paige lunges off the platform and trips on a wooden crate that's part of the set. She flies through the air-- oddly gracefully.
从后台，她的宝宝开始哭泣。佩奇从平台上猛冲下来，绊倒在作为布景一部分的木箱上。她在空中飞舞——出奇地优雅。
[BANG]
[砰]
[SHORT SCREAM]
[短促的尖叫]
Oh!
哦！
And lands smack on her knee.
重重地摔在膝盖上。
OK?
还好吗？
Yeah, I'm fine.
是的，我没事。
Are you OK?
你没事吧？
Clearly she's not fine. She's on the ground, hugging her leg. Everyone circles around her. Since it was blood drive day, there's a student volunteer there, still  in his EMS uniform. He checks her leg to see if it's broken. It's not-- just a really bad bruise.
很明显她有事。她坐在地上，抱着腿。大家围了过来。因为今天是献血日，那里有个学生志愿者，还穿着EMS制服。他检查她的腿看有没有骨折。没有——只是一个很严重的淤青。
Paige is crying. Her baby is crying. She's cradling the baby in her arms. Someone turns the spotlight on them. Paige looks like the Virgin Mary.
佩奇哭了。她的宝宝在哭。她怀里抱着宝宝。有人把聚光灯转向她们。佩奇看起来像圣母玛利亚。
[WAILING]
[啼哭]
At this point, Paige decides she's ready to cheat. One of her friends tells her to take off the bracelet. Paige wriggles it off her wrist and hands the baby and the bracelet to the girl, who gets to work triaging.
此时，佩奇决定她要作弊。她的一个朋友告诉她把手镯摘掉。佩奇扭动着把它从手腕上褪下来，递给那个女孩，女孩开始忙着处理。
Burping.
拍嗝。
I tried feeding.
我试过喂食了。
Rocking. Burping?
摇晃。拍嗝？
I did.
我试过了。
Yeah, she did.
是的，她试过了。
Feeding.
喂食。
It just needed to be held.
它只需要被抱着。
It needed to be held?
它只需要被抱着？
Yeah, it just needed to be held. And I burped it, but I didn't make any burping noises.
是的，它只需要被抱着。我给它拍嗝了，但我没弄出拍嗝的声音。
Do you want me to grab the nurse, see if she--
你要我叫护士来看看她吗——
How you feeling about motherhood now, Paige?
佩奇，你现在对母性有什么感觉？
I hate it! I'm just kidding, just kidding. (CRYING)  It's been really stressful. I just-- oh. Sorry. I'm in so much pain.
我讨厌它！开个玩笑，开个玩笑。（哭泣）这太有压力了。我只是——哦。抱歉。我太疼了。
I ask the girls to record themselves on their phones at night whenever their babies wake them up. Here's Rachel.
我让女孩们在晚上宝宝吵醒她们时，用手机记录下来。这是瑞秋。
And so it begins.
开始了。
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
(SUBJECT) [DIGITAL BEEP]
(主体) [数码哔哔声]
This is the first time she's woken me up. It's 11:30 PM.
这是她第一次把我吵醒。现在是晚上11:30。
[CRYING]
[啼哭]
Diaper changing and the bottle have not worked. I'm attempting to rock the baby.
换尿布和奶瓶都没管用。我正尝试摇晃她。
[CRYING, BUT CALMER]
[啼哭，但冷静下来]
[STOPS CRYING]
[停止哭泣]
She appears to have stopped. Hopefully she'll be sated for a while. Rachel, over and out.
她好像停止了。希望她能安静一会儿。瑞秋，完毕。
(SUBJECT) [SILENCE]
(主体) [静默]
[SCREAMING AND CRYING]
[尖叫和哭泣]
(SUBJECT) [DIGITAL BEEP]
(主体) [数码哔哔声]
This is wake-up number two, about five minutes later.
这是第二次惊醒，大概五分钟后。
[MURMURS]
[嘟囔]
It seems like she doesn't really need anything. She's just lonely, I guess.
看来她什么都不需要。我想她只是寂寞了。
[COOING]
[咕咕声]
(SINGING)  Oh, once I had a little dog. Its color, it was brown. I taught him for to whistle--
(唱) 哦，我曾有只小狗。它的毛色是棕色。我教它吹哨子——
It is 4:13. The baby is hungry again.
现在是4:13。宝宝又饿了。
[GULPING]
[吞咽声]
[HEAVY SIGH] The tiredness is really setting in. I've grown strangely emotionally attached to this lump of plastic. It'll be a tiny bit sad to get rid of her.
[重重的叹息] 疲惫感真的袭来了。我莫名其妙地对这块塑料产生了感情。要丢掉她会有点难过。
[GULPING]
[吞咽声]
Rachel records herself every single time the baby wakes her up both nights, a total of nine times. Paige was so overwhelmed by the night wakings that she didn't wind up recording herself at all.
瑞秋在两晚里每次宝宝吵醒她都记录了下来，总共九次。佩奇被半夜惊醒搞得焦头烂额，甚至没记录下自己。
Like, I don't-- I am so, so tired. And my whole-- I don't know why, but I feel like my whole body has just been slammed up against a wall. I just-- I can barely keep my eyes open, and I just feel so exhausted.
就像，我不知道——我太累了。我的全身——我不知道为什么，我觉得我的身体好像被重重摔在墙上。我只是——我几乎睁不开眼，我感到非常精疲力竭。
And, uh-- and how were you feeling while it was going on? Were you feeling mad at the baby?
而且，嗯——当它发生时，你感觉如何？你对宝宝感到愤怒吗？
A little bit. I-- I was like, man, I just-- my Mama came in and said, "Well, scan it, sweetheart." And I remember saying, "I already did." And then I, like, took her diaper off, threw the diaper, put the diaper back on, and she still was crying. And I looked at my mom and said, "Mo-om."
有一点。我——我当时想，天哪，我只是——我妈妈走过来说：“宝贝，扫描一下。”我记得我说：“我已经扫描过了。”然后我取下尿布，扔掉尿布，换上新尿布，她还在哭。我看着妈妈说：“妈——”
And so-- and around third time she woke up, I was like-- [SNARLS]
大约第三次她醒来时，我想—— [嘶吼]
I just wanted everyone to be quiet and leave me alone.
我只是希望所有人安静，让我一个人待着。
The next day at school, Rachel was not herself.
第二天在学校，瑞秋不像她自己了。
Before Chorus, Katie Schultz-- who was actually, she plays the nun in the play. She just asked me, "How's the baby?" And I just went-- (SHRILLY) "Can everyone just shut up?" And in my mind, I was like, she wasn't doing anything. She was not the person I should be yelling at. But I was just like-- [SCREAMS]
合唱课前，凯蒂·舒尔茨——她在剧中演修女。她只是问我：“宝宝怎么样？”我立刻就—— (尖锐地) “大家能不能闭嘴？”我心里想，她又没做什么。她不是我该吼的那个人。但我只是—— [尖叫]
Overnight, Paige and Rachel have become animals I recognize intimately. They've become mothers, throwing their minds, bodies, and hearts so fully into a tiny being that they can't help but whine and lash out at people who don't deserve it.
一夜之间，佩奇和瑞秋变成了我熟悉的那种动物。她们变成了母亲，将自己的身心和灵魂完全投入到一个微小的生命中，以至于她们忍不住抱怨，并对那些无辜的人发泄。
Even Paige says she's become a jerk-- or her version of a jerk. She forgot to thank a boy who held the door for her. Plus, she admits to me that she's cheated a second time. She forgot to bring her costume for dress rehearsal, so she slipped the bracelet off again and left the baby with a friend while she ran home.
连佩奇都说她变成了一个混蛋——或者说她版本的混蛋。她忘了感谢一个帮她开门的男孩。而且，她向我承认她第二次作弊了。她忘了带演出服，所以她再次脱掉手镯，在跑回家时把宝宝留给了朋友。
Next morning comes the moment of truth. The girls hand in their babies and get their grades. The robot baby keeps a minute-by-minute record of how you did. Paige goes first.
第二天早上是审判时刻。女孩们交还了宝宝，并拿到了分数。机器人婴儿保留了你照顾它的每一分钟记录。佩奇先来。
This is a 71.
这是71分。
71-- which is what, in letters?
71分——那换算成字母是什么？
A C-minus.
C-minus。
And what did she get points deducted for?
她是因为什么被扣分的？
For-- she had a missed feeding, a head support, and then 6:49, she had a missed feeding and a head support. 6:58, she had a missed burp. And 9:29-- yeah, so.
因为——她错过了一次喂食，一次头部支撑，然后在6:49，她又错过了一次喂食和头部支撑。6:58，她错过了一次拍嗝。9:29——是的，所以。
Yeah.
是的。
All right.
好吧。
It's all right.  Don't worry. Don't fret.
没关系。别担心，别烦恼。
I didn't want all that to happen. 'Cause I-- every time she cried, I picked her up immediately, gave her her bottle. If she didn't want that, I put her diaper on. So I don't know. I thought I did OK. I didn't think I'd get, like, a C. So, a little disappointed.
我不希望这些发生。因为我——每次她哭，我马上就抱起她，给她奶瓶。如果她不想要，我就换尿布。所以我不知道。我想我表现得还可以。我没想到会拿C。所以，有点失望。
Rach, let me get your grade for you.
瑞秋，我给你看你的成绩。
The big moment for Rachel. She's getting her grade.
瑞秋的重大时刻。她正在拿成绩。
Aaaaah.
啊啊啊。
94.
94分。
Which translates to an A?
这意味着是A？
An A, yeah.
是一个A，没错。
If I were a betting person, I'd have never put money on Rachel doing better than Paige-- especially not this much better. For all of her baby clothes and maternal instinct-- not to mention wanting to be a young mom-- Paige turns out to be a below-average mother, at least when it comes to plastic children.
如果我是个会打赌的人，我绝不会押瑞秋比佩奇表现好——尤其好这么多。尽管她准备了婴儿衣服和母性本能——更不用说想要早点成为妈妈——结果佩奇在照顾塑料婴儿方面竟是个低于平均水平的母亲。
Has this changed the way you feel about becoming a mother and about babies?
这是否改变了你对成为母亲和对婴儿的看法？
Um, I thought, like, I could have a baby at 21. I'll go to ministry school, meet a man of God, a man of my dreams. We'll get married and have a baby. But I think-- maybe-- maybe I think I-- maybe a little older than I thought? Like, I-- I cannot even imagine putting a baby, a life, into my world. And I think it'd be horrible.
嗯，我以前想，比如我在21岁时生个孩子。我会去牧师学校，遇到上帝挑选的人，我梦想中的男人。我们会结婚并生个孩子。但我想——也许——也许我认为我——也许应该比我想的再大一点？比如，我——我甚至无法想象把一个婴儿，一个生命，带入我的世界。我觉得那会很糟糕。
Paige isn't sure how old she wants to be when she starts a family now. She just knows she can't even picture it. Her whole life plan has been thrown out of whack by her robot baby.
佩奇现在不确定她想在多大时组建家庭了。她只知道她甚至无法想象。她的人生规划被机器人宝宝搞乱了。
My response to the baby was almost the opposite of Paige's, in that if I have a baby really young, I feel like I would keep the baby.
我对宝宝的反应几乎和佩奇相反，如果我真的很年轻生孩子，我觉得我会留下孩子。
I also never would have guessed that Paige and Rachel would flip their positions.
我也没料到佩奇和瑞秋会反转位置。
Because I kind of like the feeling of having a baby. Like for some reason, like, I guess the idea that someone or something needs you and only you kind of makes you feel all, like, important.
因为我有点喜欢照顾宝宝的感觉。因为某些原因，比如，我想这种感觉就像是有人或什么东西需要你，而且只需要你，会让你感觉——很重要。
It was awful, but at the same time, like, I was-- I kind of liked it. I'd never really thought that I would want to have a kid younger, but maybe I would.
虽然过程很糟糕，但同时，我——我还挺喜欢的。我从未想过想早点要孩子，但也许我愿意。
Rachel called it early-onset baby fever and said her mom was freaked out by it. I asked one of Rachel's teachers, and the president of the company that makes the babies, about this ironic and unintended outcome-- that the robot baby made a teenage girl want to have a real one.
瑞秋称之为“早发婴儿热”，说她妈妈被吓坏了。我问了瑞秋的一位老师，以及制造这些婴儿的公司总裁，关于这个具有讽刺意味的意外结果——机器人宝宝让一个少女想要生个真实的孩子。
They both said this was rare. They shrugged it off. The teacher said she was sure Rachel's the kind of girl who will make a thoughtful decision about when to have her own child.
他们都说这种情况很少见。他们没放在心上。老师说她确定瑞秋是那种会对自己何时生孩子做出深思熟虑决定的女孩。
Overall, the girls had a way more authentic mothering experience with the robot babies than I'd expected. But the moments when Rachel and Paige couldn't be available to the babies-- when Rachel gave blood, when Paige fell-- the girls lost points in those moments. When you're a real parent, those things happen all the time.
总的来说，女孩们通过机器人宝宝获得了比我预想中更真实的育儿体验。但当瑞秋和佩奇无法对宝宝负责的时刻——当瑞秋献血时，当佩奇摔倒时——女孩们在那些时刻丢了分。当你是一个真正的父母，那些事情一直都在发生。
Diagnosing whether your kid needs to be fed or diapered or rocked, that's not what makes you a pro at parenting. It's coping with the stress of getting it wrong, of feeling like an amateur. Which is going to happen, no matter how much practice you've had.
诊断你的孩子是需要喂食、换尿布还是摇晃，这并不能让你成为育儿专家。应对做错事情、感觉自己是个业余选手的压力才是。无论你有多少练习，这种情况都会发生。
Hillary Frank. She's the host of the parenting podcast The Longest Shortest Time, which I have to say is great, because unlike most parenting stuff, it is not actually designed specifically for parent listeners. It's for anybody. It's distributed by Earwolf.
希拉里·弗兰克。她是育儿播客《最长最短的时间》的主持人，我得说这个播客很棒，因为与大多数育儿内容不同，它不是专门为父母设计的，它是为任何人准备的。由Earwolf分发。
Act Three. "Commander In Brief." Now we have the story of an amateur who, for one night, gets thrown into a very, very big job, one of the biggest jobs. They basically get thrown in as the substitute teacher for a class they have never taught or never taken-- specifically, they're supposed to sub for the President of the United States. Stephanie Foo explains.
第三幕，“简报中的指挥官”。现在我们要讲一个业余选手的故事，他在一晚的时间里，被扔进了一个非常、非常重大的职位，可以说是最大的职位之一。他们基本上被扔进去当了代课老师，教的是他们从未教过也从未上过的课——具体来说，他们得代行美国总统的职责。斯蒂芬妮·傅为你解释。
If somebody needs to sub for the President, the chain is clear. If the Vice President can't do it, it goes to the Speaker of the House, then the President pro tempore of the Senate, then the Secretary of State, Secretary of the Treasury, Secretary of Defense, all the way down the Cabinet to Energy, Education, Veteran Affairs. It's been this way since the Presidential Succession Act of 1947. But what happens if all of those people are in one room?
如果有人需要代行总统职权，继任链很清晰。如果副总统不能代行，继任者是众议院议长，然后是参议院临时议长，接着是国务卿、财政部长、国防部长，一直排到能源、教育、退伍军人事务部。自1947年《总统继任法》以来一直如此。但如果所有人都在同一个房间里会发生什么？
Mr. Speaker, Mr. Vice President, members of Congress, my fellow Americans.
议长先生，副总统先生，国会议员们，我的美国同胞们。
The State of the Union address. What if someone blows up the building and kills everyone on that list all at once? Well, then the presidency goes to the designated survivor.
国情咨文演说。如果有人炸掉大楼，同时杀死了名单上的所有人怎么办？那么总统职位就由“指定幸存者”来担任。
That is a person chosen every year before the State of the Union speech to survive. That's their whole job-- to survive, run the United States government as an amateur president, total beginner, whose first day on the job may include wreaking vengeance upon-slash-surrendering to whoever killed all our top leaders.
那是每年在国情咨文演讲前选出的一位幸存者。这就是他们的全部工作——生存下去，作为业余总统管理美国政府，一个完全的新手，其上任的第一天可能包括向杀害我们所有领导人的人寻求报复或投降。
Each year, the designated survivor is assigned a security detail and moved to a safe, secret location away from the Capitol. This all began-- no surprise-- during the Cold War. Thomas Reed was an assistant to President Reagan for national security policy. And it was his job to figure out what to do if a nuclear weapon hit DC. He's the one who came up with the idea of the designated survivor.
每年，指定幸存者会被分配一个安保分队，并被转移到远离国会大厦的安全秘密地点。这一切始于——不出所料——冷战期间。托马斯·里德曾是里根总统的国家安全政策助理。他负责构思如果核武器击中华盛顿该怎么办。他是提出“指定幸存者”想法的人。
Washington was targeted with over 300 Soviet nuclear weapons. They had hundreds laid that were going to lay down on every possible escape route. And to think you could escape that barrage was nonsense.
华盛顿被超过300枚苏联核武器瞄准。他们部署了数百枚导弹，准备覆盖每一个可能的撤离路线。所以认为你可以逃脱那阵弹幕简直是胡说八道。
Well, I was nervous in that I remember saying, "Jeez, I know this is not going to happen. What if something does happen?"
嗯，我很紧张，因为我记得我说过：“天哪，我知道这不会发生。但如果真的发生了怎么办？”
That's Bill Richardson, former Secretary of Energy, designated survivor for the 2000 State of the Union. Richardson wasn't sent into a bunker somewhere. He was in a small town in Maryland having dinner at his friend's house, which was surrounded by a security detail and emergency vehicles. Inside, they had steak.
那是比尔·理查森，前能源部长，2000年国情咨文的指定幸存者。理查森并没有被送进什么地堡。他在马里兰州的一个小镇上朋友家里吃晚饭，那里被安保分队和紧急车辆包围。在屋里，他们吃的是牛排。
We had a nice meal. But then we sat in front of the television, and I was smoking a cigar. I had a glass of wine after it was all over.
我们吃了一顿美餐。但后来我们坐在电视机前，我抽着雪茄。一切结束后我喝了一杯酒。
I talked to a couple of designated survivors from the Cold War era, who said they were put on planes and flown to undisclosed locations. One of them got training where he got to play war games in this secret Doctor Strangelove -esque setting. And they asked him questions like, "OK, do you swear in immediately after the President's death? Do you launch missiles at the Soviets? Do you hold your fire?"
我和冷战时代的几位指定幸存者聊过，他们说他们被送上飞机飞往未公开的地点。其中一人接受了训练，在那设置如同《奇爱博士》般的秘密基地里玩战争游戏。他们问他诸如：“好了，总统死后你是否立即宣誓就职？你是否对苏联发射导弹？还是按兵不动？”
He said the training was so helpful, so enlightening, that he thought nobody should become a designated survivor without undergoing it first. But by the end of the Cold War-- post-Gorbachev, pre-9/11-- things got a little more lax.
他说训练非常有帮助，非常深刻，他认为没有人应该在不接受训练的情况下成为指定幸存者。但在冷战结束时——戈尔巴乔夫之后，9/11之前——情况变得松懈了一些。
Can you say that I went through any kind of training course about what to do? The answer is no.
你能说我接受过任何关于该怎么做的培训课程吗？答案是不能。
That's Dan Glickman, Secretary of Agriculture, designated survivor during the 1997 State of the Union.
那是丹·格利克曼，农业部长，1997年国情咨文的指定幸存者。
I think I did discuss it with my wife, that I could handle it something terrible happened. And she says, "Well, good luck."
我想我和妻子讨论过，如果发生了可怕的事情，我能应付。她说：“好吧，祝你好运。”
Donna Shalala, who was Secretary of Health and Human Services, designated survivor in 1996, didn't get any special training either. And she didn't even leave the neighborhood. She was just two and a half miles away from the Capitol-- at the White House.
唐娜·沙拉拉，曾任卫生与公众服务部长，1996年的指定幸存者，也没有接受过任何特殊训练。她甚至没离开附近。她离国会大厦只有2.5英里——在白宫。
So I took my senior staff to the Roosevelt Room at the White House, and we had pizza and watched the State of the Union. And I sort of wandered into the Oval Office and tried out the chair.
所以我带了高级职员去白宫的罗斯福厅，我们吃了披萨，观看了国情咨文。我有点溜进了椭圆形办公室，试坐了那把椅子。
What did it feel like?
感觉怎么样？
Big. Too big for me. President Clinton's a very large man.
很大。对我来说太大了。克林顿总统是个非常高大的人。
One designated survivor told me that actually attending the State of the Union is a pain. You have to look attentive and interested and approving for a really long time, in case the cameras pan to you. Being designated survivor? Much easier.
一位指定幸存者告诉我，实际上出席国情咨文是一种折磨。你必须长时间保持专注、感兴趣且赞同，以防摄像机扫到你。成为指定幸存者？容易多了。
One guy, who asked I not use his name, went on a vacation to the Caribbean when he got the gig. Not a government expense, he was quick to tell me. He happened to have plans to go anyway. Another designated survivor took the opportunity to move to a new house. A caravan of Secret Service guarded him as he loaded up his moving van.
一个人，要求我不使用他的名字，在他接到这个任务时去加勒比海度假。他很快告诉我这不是政府买单，他本来就计划去。另一位指定幸存者借机搬到了新家。特勤局的车队守护着他，帮他装好搬家货车。
One thing you might have noticed from the designated survivors I spoke to-- none of them had day jobs that had anything to do with national security. Usually it's the non-marquee Cabinet members-- Secretary of the Interior, Energy, Commerce, Agriculture-- people whose names you probably don't know. Ever heard of Anthony Foxx? He's our Secretary of Transportation-- and this year's designated survivor.
你可能从我采访过的指定幸存者那里注意到一件事——他们中没有人的日常工作与国家安全有关。通常是那些非头牌的内阁成员——内政部长、能源、商务、农业部长——你可能不知道名字的人。听说过安东尼·福克斯吗？他是我们的交通部长——也是今年的指定幸存者。
And when I heard about that, I kind of thought, well, seriously? The decision to launch nuclear retaliation, kill millions of people, could possibly rest in the hands of the Secretary of Transportation? Thomas Reed, the guy who designed this program, says, "Why not? The Secretary of Transportation is as good a person as any."
当我听到这个时，我心想，好吧，认真的吗？发动核报复、杀害数百万人这样决定的权利，竟然可能掌握在交通部长手中？托马斯·里德，设计这个项目的人说：“为什么不呢？交通部长和任何人一样好。”
The question in politics, and all other things in life, is, "Compared to who?" The question is not, "Is So-and-so authorized or qualified to be President, or Governor, or successor? The question is, "Compared to who?" Compared to Joseph Stalin? Of course. Compared to Dwight Eisenhower? Probably not.
政治以及生活中所有事情的问题在于：“和谁比？”问题不在于：“某某是否有权或有资格担任总统、州长或继任者？”问题是：“和谁比？”和斯大林比？当然有资格。和艾森豪威尔比？可能没资格。
And the Cabinet, they're all brilliant people, and certainly have the wherewithal to at least make the initial decisions.
内阁成员都是聪明人，而且肯定有能力至少做出初步决定。
[CHUCKLES QUIETLY] Stephanie, they're not all brilliant people, any more than you or I are. And they all have problems, and some smoke too much, and some are overweight, and so forth and so on. They're all human beings.
[轻轻笑] 斯蒂芬妮，他们不是所有都是聪明人，就像你我一样。他们都有问题，有些人烟抽太多，有些人超重等等。他们都是凡人。
And, Reed said, the President's been chosen by the American people, and the President chooses the designated survivor. So therefore, by proxy, that person is chosen by the American people.
里德说，总统是由美国人民选出的，而总统选择指定幸存者。所以，通过这种代理，那个人也是由美国人民选出的。
Sometimes they choose well. Sometimes they don't. That's what politics is all about.
有时他们选得好，有时选不好。这就是政治的一切。
That's a very ominous statement.
那是一个非常不祥的陈述。
[LAUGHS] Yes. Yes, it is.
[笑] 是的，是的。
Here's Dan Glickman again, designated survivor, 1997, Secretary of Agriculture.
这是丹·格利克曼，1997年指定幸存者，农业部长。
You know, I mean, I was not really briefed on what to do if something were to happen to the President. But you know, I have enough confidence in myself that if something were to happen, I would have followed certain basic rules, and would have been a good soldier, in that case.
你知道，我的意思是，如果总统出了什么事，我并没有真正收到关于该做什么的简报。但你知道，我有足够的自信，如果发生了什么，我会遵循某些基本原则，在那情况下，我会成为一名好士兵。
When Glickman was a designated survivor, they flew him to LaGuardia Airport in a G3 plane, along with some stern-looking guys in suits-- one of whom may or may not have been carrying the nuclear football in a fancy briefcase. Then they got Glickman in a three-car caravan, drove him to his daughter's modest apartment in Manhattan's West Village, and stood guard outside while he watched the speech on TV. Glickman admitted he did imagine what it would be like.
当格利克曼担任指定幸存者时，他们用G3飞机把他送到了拉瓜迪亚机场，随行的还有几个穿着西装看起来很严肃的家伙——其中一个人可能正提着装有核密码箱的精美公文包。然后他们安排格利克曼坐上三辆车的车队，开车把他送到曼哈顿西村他女儿那间简朴的公寓，并在外面守卫，而他在电视上观看了演讲。格利克曼承认他确实想象过那会是什么样子。
I did think about it. It was a very interesting thing that here, the Secretary of Agriculture could be President of the United States. And I'd been telling the world all these years that agriculture was the most important part of our government, so you know, I could reinforce that message, certainly.
我确实想过。这很有趣，这里，农业部长竟然可能成为美国总统。这些年来我一直告诉世界农业是我们政府最重要的部分，所以你知道，我当然可以加强那个信息。
[LAUGHS] All of a sudden, that would be our number-one national agenda, is just agriculture.
[笑] 突然间，那将成为我们国家的第一号日程，就是农业。
Agriculture. Food and agriculture.
农业。食品和农业。
Glickman even said that in his regular job, he was so unimportant that immediately after the speech was over, he lost the security detail. They bailed on him and went back to Washington.
格利克曼甚至说，在他常规工作中，他是如此不重要，以至于演讲结束后，他立刻就失去了安保分队。他们抛下他回了华盛顿。
In fact, their exact words were, "Mr. Glickman, the mission is terminated." And I decided to stay in New York and have dinner with my daughter. And it was cold and raining and sleeting, and once the dinner was over, we went outside of the restaurant, and we couldn't find a cab.
事实上，他们的原话是：“格利克曼先生，任务已终止。”我决定留在纽约和我女儿吃晚饭。外面又冷又下着雨夹雪，晚饭结束后，我们走出餐厅，找不到出租车。
So we walked back, about 12 blocks, back to my daughter's apartment in a sleet storm. And it struck me that just three or four hours before, I was the most powerful man on the face of the Earth, for about an hour. And now I couldn't even get a cab.
所以我们在雨夹雪中步行了大约12个街区回到女儿的公寓。我突然意识到，就在三四个小时前，我还是地球上最有权势的人，大约一小时。现在我连车都打不到。
The fact of the matter is, no first-term president goes into office knowing how to be president. He learns on the job. Everything's new.
事实是，没有一个第一任总统在上任时就知道如何当总统。他是边干边学的。一切都是新的。
And opening that briefcase and deciding whether to launch a nuclear strike? Nobody could be ready for that. The President might be as likely to make the wrong choice as the Secretary of Agriculture. Or the Secretary of Transportation, or the White House intern, or you, or I.
至于打开那个公文包决定是否发动核打击？没有人能对此做好准备。总统犯错的可能性可能和农业部长一样大。或者交通部长、白宫实习生，或者你，或者我。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M DOING" BY DEAN MARTIN]
[音乐 - 迪恩·马丁的《我不知道我在做什么》]
ACT 4:
第四幕：
Well, our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Joe Richman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show  is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell. Technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lyra Smith.
好的，我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·傅制作，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、乔·里奇曼、罗宾·塞门、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。乔尔·洛弗尔提供编辑帮助。技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。莱拉·史密斯提供制作帮助。
Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和米歇尔·哈里斯提供研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供音乐帮助。
Special thanks today to Derrick Brown for telling us about the Soldier Safety Show at Fort Bragg. Derrick goes on tour with Greg Dulli and The Afghan Whigs this March. Find out where at brownpoetry.com.
特别感谢德里克·布朗向我们讲述布拉格堡的士兵安全秀。德里克将于今年3月与格雷格·杜利和阿富汗辉格乐队巡演。在brownpoetry.com上可以查到巡演地点。
Thanks to Lisa Pollak for cluing us in about designated survivors. Thanks to Joanna Solotaroff, Alex Kapelman, Maria DiCondina, Brian Haley, Rusty Hodgkinson, Quincy Billups, Victor Hurtado, Evan Middlesworth at Pine Hollow Audio, and the teachers and students at Glen Ridge High School.
感谢丽莎·波拉克为我们提供有关指定幸存者的线索。感谢乔安娜·索洛塔罗夫、亚历克斯·卡佩尔曼、玛丽亚·迪康迪纳、布莱恩·黑利、拉斯蒂·霍金森、昆西·比拉普斯、维克多·乌尔塔多、埃文·米德尔斯沃思在Pine Hollow Audio的工作，以及格伦里奇高中的师生们。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who hears his name right here in the credits every single week-- every single week. And he asks--
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他每周——每周都在职员表中听到自己的名字。他问——
What the-- what are we doing? Why are we doing this?
到底——我们在做什么？为什么我们要这么做？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给你更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M DOING" BY DEAN MARTIN]
[音乐 - 迪恩·马丁的《我不知道我在做什么》]